new drama for today's episode of as the
documents turn get the rubber gloves
ready because the doj could expand the
Biden document search to other sensitive
locations Dana get your mind out of the
gutter
we're talking about the beach house
don't worry though Biden's lawyers have
everything under control and we just got
exclusive video of their consensual
search
yeah there you go they really left no
stone unturned meanwhile there are a lot
of lingering questions but by
unqualified talking head is not too keen
on answering them
after a special counsel was named but
before the FBI searched
President Biden went to his house in
Wilmington what was he doing in there I
would refer you to the White House
Council so it was something relating to
this case I would refer you to the White
House council's Office okay do you think
that this story was leaked by someone
trying to bruise the president
politically ahead of a re-election
announcement I would refer to the White
House counsel's office we know the
president did it
why did he do it
I would refer to the White House Council
the best
so let's check in with the White House
counsel's Office
there are many people uh out there in
the media who sort of try to stir up
controversy to get attention or uh or
time on camera the underlying issue that
we're talking about here is that as soon
as the president's personal team noticed
something they immediately and promptly
and transparently disclose that to the
proper authorities
everyone in Biden's orbit keeps spinning
but some top Democrats are not buying it
the process we go through is so
elaborate and careful to review any of
these documents that I can't understand
how any individual Senator can take
possession of a classified document let
alone remove it to another location it's
just Unthinkable I never take classified
documents to my house I don't know any
reason why people would I am very very
careful about it and I would assume that
everyone else is but clearly there's a
problem here and in a major plot twist
former vice president Mike Pence found
classified documents at his home in
Indiana last week and turned them over
to the FBI Jesse so Trump was right
about Pence
I'm joking um I mean Pence seriously
yeah we have this great thing going with
Joe yeah and he just ruined it and come
on man
well what are we gonna do and then he
confessed to it I mean he could have
just destroyed it we never would have
known and we have to be fair and
balanced and show both sides I know now
we have to show both sides
and you know Pence is so clean so
squeaky clean it's clean it's nothing
like the real bad documents that Joe
Biden was squirreling away do you think
he just wanted to be included he's like
hey I'm running for president too yes
investor gave me I looked at secret
stuff
but this does hurt but remember how
Biden was trying to put himself against
Trump like oh Trump was Reckless and he
had him at Mar-A-Lago and you know it
was I did it consensually you know my
search was consensual and I've
cooperated and transparent
compared to Trump he could maybe make
that argument even though he's the VP
and he doesn't have classification
Authority but now you compare Biden to
Pence
and Biden doesn't look so clean Pence
didn't even open the box yeah Pence had
the Box still taped up and then when
someone looked at it he put it in a safe
and called the archive it's like that
hey
come on not what Biden did he didn't
have it next to a Corvette you know he
didn't have it at the think tank so it
is a little bit different but come on
Mike it is getting it is worse than
whatever Trump did because hey he can't
that not being able to classify it is a
big deal both of those guys pension but
I think we should rate Gore's house yes
Obama's yeah yeah in Hawaii who knows
that go all the way back to Kenya Jesse
um that's a joke America Dana uh um I'm
not laughing you should are there a lot
of people that work in the white house
now that are are like a wave of people
getting ready to have classified dogs
removed I just I I just feel like they
are sitting there going you mean that we
he did better in the midterms than we
thought we were going to do we take back
the Senate and we've spent the first
five weeks of this term talking about
the president having classified
documents at several homes even going
back to his Senate days after he said
that Trump was so irresponsible and I
just think it is a shame it's a shame
because one people do get in trouble for
mishandling classified documents they
could be fired their reputations could
be learned ruined they could never work
in their their profession again in their
field or they could even be prosecuted
and do jail time so
if if Biden had just said at the
beginning whoa I shouldn't have done
that irresponsible we're gonna we're
gonna have this consensual search we're
good here they could move on I also
think it hurts this this white house
when they can't even answer just like
basic questions for example I don't
understand why you have to refer to the
White House council's Office this
question do you think that people should
handle classified documents
appropriately I refer you to the White
House counsel's Office like you can't
even answer that that's bad
do you know what that tells me right
that tells me that when you can't answer
a simple question like that you know
when instead prefer the drip drip drip
of what's going on it almost seems like
she's referring to the president as a
defendant you have to speak to his
lawyer about that she's not referring to
and I heard Jonathan Turley talk about
this early she's not referring to the
president as the president but rather as
a person who may be a suspect in a
criminal investigation she's not doing
them any favor but I got to tell you the
one thing Jesse that is so much worse
and we can go what about is them and I
think at the end of this there's got to
be some new rules on this stuff because
everybody's violating it so it appears
but when you go into a skiff and you
come out of that skiff I mean you're not
entitled to that to that document you
can't even read it until you go on the
Skip and then you take it home when
you're a senator I mean Durkin and ship
themselves went after Biden for that
that's where Biden's awesome trouble
also they're fine how many home home
says Biden have I mean what a little bit
of lucrative career for a politician I
mean and a school teacher never had a
private you for 50 years and he's got I
mean all this money I almost think
that's a sign of corruption that went on
for decades that's what Harold was
saying in the Green Room you said that
you said uh people that were found with
classified documents we should execute
them Harold that's what you said did I
say that yes
it's good to be back
two two things one said to to the
judge's point with uh Mr ampere I think
that the White House has chosen Dana to
to pursue a legal strategy at the
expense of a PR strategy and I think we
saw that today whether that's right or
wrong whether that is something we
prefer or not that's where they are
to um there's no doubt judge we need
that they're going to have to reevaluate
how uh documents are classified how long
they stay classify and for that matter
how when vice presidents and presidents
leave the vice president the Naval
Observatory in the White House how they
account for what they have and what they
don't have and perhaps instead of
allowing staffs to uh to pack them up
they may have to have professionals
those who know how to do this and deal
with this kind of information these
documents come in or at least help
oversee that process but look we can
talk about the differences between the
three but without question you have the
president the vice president former vice
president former president and now
current president two of them with
special counsels looking into this and
it could very well be that it could rise
to the level with Mr Pence now what's
interesting to me it remains interesting
to me about President Biden's situation
November 14th said it before
um president attorney general Garland
decided to appoint the U.S attorney from
Illinois the Republican appointed U.S
attorney by Mr Trump to oversee what
they discovered November 2nd or 3rd from
November 4th to January 5th it seemed
fine and all of a sudden attorney
general Garland decided to appoint a
special counsel uh in President Biden's
situation to oversee so something
happened there's some standard much like
with President Trump there was a
standard I don't believe that President
Trump Declassified all those things
those his lawyers would have just said
from the very beginning furthermore you
can't declassify things if you're no
longer the president but if he
Declassified it when he was president
but his lawyers didn't his lawyers have
not here's what happened all I'm saying
is there are two special counsels have
been one for each of them which means
some standard has been breached or some
standard has been triggered it doesn't
appear from the language from vice
president Pence the former vice
president Pence since the boxes were
sealed like I've not heard anyone fully
ask President Biden were those boxes
open we've all assumed that they were
all open we've even circled something in
his garage looking at the picture
thinking that thinking that's the stuff
but if those boxes were open that's a
big difference between vice president
and president and President Biden and so
I want to agreeing with you I just don't
the declassification thing I do not
agree with but I think it's important to
make the distinction the difference
between having the Attorney General look
at it and then a special counsel is they
the doj knew about it as you say on
November 14th but then on December 20th
or December 18th they found more and
nobody knew about it that's to me the
change where now we need a special
that's why we heard that the justice
department said that they don't trust
yeah fully the Biden private lawyers
exactly well whatever there's something
that's clear because that that and this
is a Democrat appointed attorney general
matter of fact the president himself
appointed him so something something is
something is
what president Trump and president with
President Trump
appoint a real trustworthy person as
attorney general they'll turn on you and
they'll disappoint a special counsel to
investigate you that's because as a
standard had been breached that's why
they stopped it's politics you know I'm
just my pen stated earlier that he would
never be alone with classified documents
but I was really good
idea from Harold a classified moving
documents company
shouldn't that be great you show up do
you have to get pizza for them to show
up a movie classified doctors Gatorade
that's all the same lunch that you're
eating yeah just water I went on Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now